the big announcement the big
announcement are we ready for the big
announcement you guys in your chairs
everyone's all right i got a fist bump i
got a i got a thumbs up the big
announcement now you may remember
people that originally we were going to
do we were going to kick off the entire
tour in orlando florida that was the
original thing and then i suddenly said
oh but something's happening we're gonna
have to move the date things are
happening a lot of people bought tickets
people were freaking out they were what
happened dave what's going on why aren't
you going to orlando now if dave rubin
says something and then dave rubin has
to you know say i'm going to be here on
this given day and then dave reuben
moves that day you know that dave rubin
has got something up his sleeve you know
what dave rubin's got up his sleeve have
you heard of this guy governor ron
desantis of the free state of florida
let's show them the image people that's
right dave rubin and governor ron
desantis will be at the plaza live it's
a huge theater about a thousand seats
june 2nd in orlando florida you can go
to daverubin.com
events to get tickets and it is
officially the last stop of the official
tour
and the governor will be there with me
look at those two smiles look at those
guys and maybe i'm gonna say gay in
front of him
people are gonna freak out it's very
exciting so yes that is why we moved the
orlando date i'm super psyched about
this obviously so i'll do my usual spiel
and get people laughing and all that
good stuff and then we're just going to
have a completely no-holds-barred
conversation
with the governor about absolutely
everything i think it's awesome that it
just happened to work out that we're
going to do this in orlando i mean that
is the home of the mouse right that is
that is disney orlando florida so we're
going right to the belly of the beast
that's by total coincidence actually too
uh we did not set it up that way but it
the the world
works in mysterious ways as they say so
i am super psyched you can get your
tickets davereuben.com
events it is one
month
from today but desantis is also firing
back on this ministry of truth nonsense
because everyone knows this has nothing
to do with truth it has everything to do
with propaganda
but clearly
our entire
principles that the country was founded
on uh you cannot have a ministry of
truth in this country and so let's get
real here let's let's make sure that
we're doing things to benefit uh
floridians and americans uh but we're
not gonna let biden get away with this
one so we'll be fighting back
yeah we're not going to let him get away
with it we're going to fight back we're
going to mock them we're going to
probably pass laws to make sure that the
rights of americans and your ability to
protest the government and speak freely
uh will be strengthened here in a place
like florida because we're winning our
playbook is working the things that
desantis has been fighting for and that
tucker has been fighting for and that
elon musk has been fighting for it's all
working we're getting post-woke so
they're getting more hysterical they're
getting more hysterical and what have i
been saying for a while and what is this
freaking book about it's about you
versus the system the system is is
trying to scare the [ __ ] out of you now
that we've gotten past up there there we
go we got demonetized no lunch for you
guys today but the system is trying to
scare you guys you get it the more that
they do this craziness it's designed to
scare you again because the covid thing
the fear of covid thing is starting to
dissipate so they need new fear and now
the new fear is don't say stuff because
we've got a ministry of truth
but one man can beat it elon's one guy
desantis is one guy judge mizell the
tampa federal judge who reversed the
mandate is one person all tucker is one
guy and then i saw this one guy who i
think is just great he's just great he
was on the glenn beck program
discussing
desantis elon musk and the rest of it
look disney lost 41 billion dollars in
the last three weeks and why did it lose
it because they've been infected and
then one man ron desantis said no more
and that that i love
the idea that one man elon musk is one
man now he may be an extraordinary
person and he's the tony stark of our
time and it's hard to imagine a guy
sending tesla's into space but he's one
guy one guy who could have done whatever
he wanted if he wanted to put his family
on a rocket tomorrow and disappear from
earth and all of our mortal problems
gone he could do it but instead he got
into the biggest fight possible the free
speech fight elon musk is one guy ron
desantis is one guy judge mazzell the 35
year old female trump appointed judge in
tampa who just said nope no more mask
mandates and then what happens
everybody rips them off covet isn't
going crazy for the last two weeks
one woman so we just need the individual
to say no to the machine